hello and welcome to a sort of Thank You
appreciation video I keep thinking I'm
going to do one of these like at 100k
subscribers and then I thought maybe
okay I'll do it 500k subscribers and
then I'm like well maybe I'll do it out
like a million I probably won't and I
think today's as good a day as any to
say thank you for seven hundred and
sixty-five thousand subscribers so the
video I was actually gonna release today
was a bit more negative lately I've been
digging into plagiarism and finding that
it's a huge or seemingly huge problem to
put this in perspective it seems like
about ten thousand people and I'm not
talking about people just like copying
and pasting accidentally or something
like that I'm talking about people who
are taking entire projects and claiming
it as their own putting them on the
resume and it's just it's a large number
of people and it's kind of a bummer but
then I think about 10,000 people and put
that in perspective of seven hundred and
sixty-five thousand subscribers and only
33 percent of you are subscribed that
gives me an audience of 2.3 million
people ten thousand people is in
significant and what I want to do today
is rather than giving airtime to the
negative stuff I just want to say thanks
for making ten thousand people
insignificant so first off thank you to
obviously all of the viewers but also
the subscribers the people who said who
saw my videos which they're just
programming education videos like this
is so much different than like a vlog
channel or like an eye candy tech
channel or something like seven hundred
sixty-five thousand of you saw cut
pretty niche programming tutorials and
click the button that basically says yes
I want more of that
right you guys are all self motivated
learners that are choosing to spend your
free time watching programming
educational videos you guys are very
rare so to have seven hundred sixty five
thousand of you that said that and like
that's a huge number that's like ten big
stadiums full of
people that said yes I want more of that
that's insane that's just truly insane
so first of all well second of all thank
you to the subscribers then there's the
donors and the channel members I'm
putting you guys together because in my
mind you're basically the same there are
no perks really I mean there are perks
to being a channel member but I'm
confident none of you are channel
members for the perks other than maybe
the the you get to see cent X uncut the
video that was going to come out today
but but otherwise mmm there's really no
perks I I'm confident you guys are all
just supporting just as support and
that's something pretty special on its
own that there's even one of you so to
all the channel members and donors thank
you very much for you know directly
supporting me financially that really
does mean a lot to me so thank you very
much there's a reason I call you guys
awesome humans in the discord I honestly
I had to come up with a name for the
group and the first thing that came to
my mind was awesome humans but that's
really what I think of you guys so thank
you
next speaking of discord we've got the
moderators and just the general discord
community has been really great it's
very difficult to have that many people
in a chat together and to keep things
relatively decent and I really do
appreciate the moderators and just the
general community keeping it a good
community also for the moderators I
don't believe I asked any of them if
they wanted to be a moderator I just
kind of like gave them the role and they
all assumed it great so thank you guys
sorry if any of you guys were burdened
with the role well along those lines
thank you to everybody who supports my
mug addiction also thank you to the
helpers in the discord these are people
again who just because they're kind
people they've decided to help countless
newbie questions in those to help
channels in the discord and you guys are
all so awesome so thank you to those
people also feel like I can't have a
thank-you video without thanking Daniel
Daniel's been working with me now
formally for like a year but he's been
with me for longer than that before I
was paying him I'm just working for free
and he puts up with my stuff I mean he
did he came in he was covered in PHP it
was it was a mess but we've got him nice
and pythonic now and like I said he puts
up with my nonsense so so thank you to
Daniel he helps helps with tutorials he
helps with okay like everything he just
he's a jack-of-all-trades in terms of
helping me with this this content
creation business thing so anyway yeah
again thank you to everybody because you
guys really truly have made the number
10,000 insignificant and sometimes just
need a reminder that you like I just
don't realize how big the channel really
is sometimes and I just forget and in in
in discovering this problem it like I
said it's kind of a bummer and then you
realize man actually it's kind of a
blessing to be so big that 10,000 people
is less than 1% like that's that's
awesome and I really do I wake up every
day and I do really whatever the heck I
want it just so happens that this is
what I want to do right but I get to
learn about new and exciting technology
I just kind of hop around and work on
and learn about things that I feel like
learning about and that's the best job I
could possibly imagine having so yeah
thank you to everybody for helping to
make that possible anyway that's all for
now I'll see you guys in another video